I'm you to gross Matos I'm here a  bleacher report to pick my Super Bowl  liner I got to get Tom Brady you get Tom  Brady you already going to the Super  Bowl so I'm gonna get robbed can nobody  got robbed  ed read every was always one of my  favorite players to watch Lawrence  Taylor because he's different he's just  a beast and all right  I prostate Jerry Rice can't go out Jerry  Rice either so I want to add ap I would  but I don't know it's just I can't I  can't not have one of these on it so all  right I got Tom Brady the goat every  Jerry Rice and Lawrence Taylor and Rob  Gronkowski if you can find someone who  can stop Rob Gronkowski old Lawrence  Taylor you know I pay you and then Jerry  Rice most receiving yards every gosh  it's my favorite safety all the time and  it's I'm ready to go  heater girls my toes I just bought my  all-time Super Bowl squad